good evening members and officers
welcome to the cabinet meeting 27th of
january 2022
fire alarm procedures if the fire alarm
is activated vacate the offices via the
stairs please do not use the lifts
assembling hawley square on the green
officers will assist you and advise when
it is deemed safe to return to the
chamber
please switch off or turn to silent your
mobile phones and do not make or receive
calls whilst the meeting is in progress
please note this meeting is being live
streamed for members of the public
the meeting will also be recorded and
will subsequently be broadcast on the
internet
i don't believe anybody's in the gallery
that would
be filming tonight
so the following members have asked to
speak under council procedure
rule 20.1
item 4 councillor yates and councillor
whitehead does it any other do any other
members wish to speak
council auburn which item
oh
so you're well
[Laughter]
and
okay
we'll move on
apologies for absence are there any
apologies for absence
nope we're all here
declarations of interest does anyone
have any interest to declare on the
items of business on the agenda this
evening
that's a no trials
minutes of the previous meeting to
approve the summary of recommendations
and decisions of the cabinet held on the
13th of january 2022
a copy is attached to the agenda pack
i propose that we approve the minutes do
i have a seconder councillor bob bayford
do members agree i agree
item 4 is the draft budget 2022-23
um
medium-term financial strategy 22-26
to introduce councillor david saunders
thank you chairman
this report presents the budget for
2022-23
along with the capital program as
previously provided to cabinet
it has however been updated to reference
the recommendations put forward by the
ovum scrutiny panel at their meeting on
the 18th of january for cabinet
consideration
it is now well versed that we were
forecasting a significant budget gap
but with a planned and cautious approach
combined with an efficient savings plan
we have been able to balance our budget
despite what may seem like a lengthy and
complicated process this level of
planning is critically important
it's how we continue to deliver the
services that matter to people and
protect and support our most vulnerable
residents
planning our finances in this way means
we are on the right track for balancing
our budget in the forthcoming years
our balanced budget position has been
supported in part by the very welcome
additional funding that has been
provided to us by government for next
year however much of this funding is
temporary and therefore careful
consideration will be given to its use
allocating these resources to the most
appropriate and prudent way
will be given
sorry will help ensure that this
authority
moves into the medium term on the most
sound financial footing possible
this is the prudent and responsible
thing to do
it is with this in mind
that we have carefully considered the
recommendations from overview and
scrutiny panel as laid out in section 11
of this report
the council is committed to the delivery
of a strategic response to the temporary
accommodation needs of homeless families
we have already committed 1.6 million
pounds to the development of our first
temporary
accommodation project
providing eight self-contained flats
and following the completion of this
project will consider further projects
to build a larger and most and more cost
effective portfolio of properties that's
our ambition
this approach will be the best way to
secure long-term savings in the cost of
temporary accommodation
the relatively small amount available
from the new homes bonus would not be
sufficient to deliver a further scheme
and its use at this stage to offset the
costs of borrowing is considered to be
more prudent
in our opinion as an option
we are exploring external funding
options and additional boring could also
be considered in the future when a
further temporary accommodation option
is identified
unfortunately we haven't identified
anything at this point in time
the funding required to address the lift
issues has been estimated to be in
excess of two hundred and thirty
thousand
in addition to this you need to consider
the ongoing maintenance and management
as such we are considering and pursuing
other long-term sustainable funding
options for the repair and ongoing
maintenance and again management of our
coastal lifts
with regards to the reserve transfer for
climate change projects the monies that
sit in the risk reserve will be
available for such projects on an as and
when needed basis furthermore we are
also looking in this area for external
funding opportunities too
as such we do not see it necessary to
transfer an amount to a dedicated
earmarked reserve
accordingly and having given the matter
due consideration we will not be
adjusting the budget to accommodate any
of the free recommendations from the
overview and scrutiny panel and will
therefore be recommending the budget to
council for approval in its current form
i'm here with the recommendations
chairman thank you
thank you councillor saunders do i have
a second councillor bob bateford
speaking under rule 20.1 councillor
yates
thank you chair
um
and thank you councillor saunders for
them responding to the comments movie
and the proposal some overview and
scrutiny um
so
on the 2022-23 budget um first of all i
think we are
um happy to hear that uh climate um
internal project management um
monies could be available from the risk
management reserve um i think my my
question here will be
is this going to be minuted just for the
record because i think that's the right
move and um i think
i'd like to say thank you
for that i think the name change well
i'm happy to let that slide if it can be
used so um thank you for that um on the
on the other issues um
i think we continue to state that the
um putting money into temporary
accommodation now um would provide a
balanced budget
and we wouldn't need uh to find
additional savings in the budget
um when it comes to
um
why we are so passionate about this we
think it's
it will produce it will reduce our
ongoing costs for tempe housing in the
future um and i guess
our response to uh properties not being
readily available to purchase is that
have we really tested that um because i
think that's still our position is that
we still think
um
that 400 000 pounds plus could be used
to find temporary housing now and the
only additional piece of information i'd
like to bring tonight is that
um as we stand as councillor saunders
has said um
it is the plan to
um
to have these the current plan to have
eight temporary housing flats uh which
are currently being built and they'll be
managed by one
temporary housing manager and i think
the quicker we can build new properties
the better to make the full use of that
resource within the council
so from our side
and and lastly just on the lifts um
obviously
we we put forward 125 000 we're now
hearing a different number
um but we do believe that fixing the
lifts is in the best interest and we
look forward to hearing
um how quickly this can be done
uh through other means but yeah we still
believe um funding um using this new
home's bonus opportunity to get the list
fixed for ramsgate and the viking bay is
the way forward so
um thank you and um i look forward to
hearing response on those issues thanks
thank you councillor yates perhaps um
chris bundle could just clarify the
terminology around the reserves and then
hand back to council so that can be
minuted and then hand back to councillor
saunders to respond on the other issues
thank you chair yes the risk management
reserve is a fairly uh broad reserve
that can be used for a uh a broad range
of purposes and the
the the governance and approval
processes are exactly the same to take
money from that reserve so this um it's
purely a terminology or linguistic sort
of issue to create a separate reserve
thank you for clarifying that and i'm
sure charles you've captured that in the
minutes so uh over to you council
saunders for the remainder of the
comment yes thank you um i'm
again happy that that point is uh
militared i'd like to thank um
the labour group for their comments and
i have personally very sorry that at
this point in time given the situation
with regards to the budget gap we're
unable to do
more than we we
can with the moneys that are available
with regards to the lift
we have been working on a strategy um i
can say that monies have been pledged
towards that strategy it's a long term
strategy
members who have heard me before will
know that as far as the viking bay lift
is concerned i feel very passionate
about that lift having been a member of
the broadstairs millennium group who
lobbied very very hard in the late 90s
to have that lift built
so
i can wax lyrically
in the same way as councillor everett
did with regards to the ramsgate list
which i do appreciate is a historic
unit
not a building
and
we'll continue to use work on the
strategy as i say
substantial monies have been pledged
towards that
situation
we've received some sponsorship from
interested parties and we will continue
to get to a situation where we have the
money a to get to the lifts repaired
and to operate those lifts long-term
rather than the short-term situation
that we've experienced in recent years
short-term in terms of the viking bay
lift unfortunately as far as the rams
gets lift is concerned
i think it's a major repair as we all
appreciate and the sooner we can get
this strategy up and running and come up
with the funds
the better thank you
thank you cancer saunders and i'd just
like to um
reassure
you um in in well all of the shadow
cabinet and members that um
our cabinet are constantly on the
lookout for land that will be suitable
and we do have social housing very high
on the list we i do appreciate that the
more housing we can provide
for um the homeless takes the bill away
from the private sector that uh we're
forced to go down that route and
obviously
um
for compassionate reasons where children
have to be moved out of the area for
their education we understand all of
that and uh
we are looking at various sites that
could be suitable and i'm sure
councillor jill bayford
can assure
everybody that that is one of our big
priorities to look at that so um social
housing is definitely up there amongst
our priorities but we need to do it in a
in a structured way that can have the
maximum amount of impact
so
just to reassure you from that point of
view
speaking again the next speaker under
20.1 is councillor whitehead
i think we're on
thank you chair and councillor saunders
i wish to be brief frankly it's
something i manage really and this
evening seems to be an apt point to try
considering the length of my
contribution at overview and scrutiny on
this issue
as members and cabinet members will be
aware i spoke at overview and scrutiny
to propose partial usage of the new
homes bonus in a housing capacity
to extend our in-house temporary housing
provision through the acquisition of
property both to reduce stress on our
community in terms of reducing
out-of-area placements and reduce our
ongoing costs both in terms of property
acquisition and in long-term reduction
of costs related to using private
providers for temporary accommodation
we will in the future need all forms of
accommodation within our portfolio both
individual and larger units and our
residents will benefit from all
i always work alongside offices and
utilize their knowledge and experience
and i strongly believe that this is
long-term a more cost effective choice
than simply setting aside the new homes
bonus which was received in no small
part due to the excellent work of
housing and our empty homes team in
bringing back 252 empty homes into use
i know that the proposed amendment is
socially logically and financially
prudent
i have not been approached by cabinet to
discuss this further although i always
welcome discussion and debate of
different approaches and ideas
and as the recording of overview and
scrutiny has not been uploaded as yet
even though later meetings have
to be certain that my points are
understood in the context of this
meeting i need to speak
from a democratic standpoint it would
also be helpful to know when the
recording of the last overview and
scrutiny meeting will be uploaded as
many residents use our recordings to
follow the workings of our council
and have a return to previous business
without a public record of the previous
business makes our processes unclear and
potentially confusing
i believe strongly in the proposed
amendment
and as everyone in this chamber knows if
i believe in something i work for it and
i fight for it if necessary
i have put in the work on this and i
will continue to
but i hoped not to have to fight for it
because i believe that the vote to take
this forward within overview and
scrutiny and the acknowledgment of
cabinet that it was sensible to consider
it speaks to its merits
we have to expand our in-house temporary
accommodation in all forms
both to help residents and to reduce
extensive and expensive future costs
i believe in the strength of my proposal
as i believe the social and economic
advantages are clear
i can and will happily argue for them
for as long as necessary
but i had hoped very much to not have to
i thank cabinet for their willingness to
consider this proposal and its merits
for i know without doubt that those
merits are significant
thank you
thank you councillor whitehead um i will
check up about the um
scrutiny i i can't answer now
as to why that hasn't been loaded thank
you i will ask that or charles if you
could ask the technical about that or if
you know the answer
you mean regarding uh the uploading of
the minutes yeah the uploading of the
the uploading of the overview and
scrutiny um meeting that night the video
the recording
i'm sorry i wasn't aware that it's not
yet on
on our website however check it out okay
check it out
um if you'd like to respond to
councillor saunders to uh i don't think
there's a question in there as much as
maybe to reiterate why why we didn't um
actually include the proposal in the
budget
i'd like to um
agree with what
much of that council whitehead has said
particularly with regards to our housing
team
i dare i say
our award win winning housing team they
do a superb job and we did consider it
in depth
and in discussion with the budget holder
and um came to the conclusion that the
sums
weren't sufficient for us to pursue
the route that we feel and the housing
team i have to say phil is the right
route to take
with regards to that amount of money yes
in normal terms
it is a significant amount of money but
in reality
when we're looking to
obtain uh refurbish and modify
accommodation or build from scratch um
it really isn't sufficient and it's
better used in the way that we propose
i'm afraid
other than that um yes do keep
on our backs as it were
that we know the situation i understand
the situation i could go on and tell you
how the situation has improved believe
it or not from my childhood days
when people were forced to go into
accommodation that was operated by
a notorious man called rachman
you probably won't know so i do
understand the situation i do come from
a free up to down
situation with outside toilet no
electricity et cetera so i do understand
the the situation we're very sympathetic
i won't
go on because steve thinks i'm going to
get my violin outside but
trust me we do understand the situation
we'll be looking at very very closely
but do keep persuading us and reminding
us thank you
thank you
next to speak under 20.1 councillor
austin
sorry sorry bob um my eyes are not good
tonight
carry on
sorry i was just going to say an outside
toilet sheer luxury
oh that was worth waiting for bob
i'm not sure i can follow that no
that's what his neighbours said anyway
before we get too lower
down down the chain on this one um
yes sorry to speak under 20.1
councillor austin thank you chair and
thank you uh um councillor saunders um
i'm here on representing the green group
i'm the only sad person who didn't have
something else to be doing this evening
and i'm here i suspect in exactly the
spirit that council saunders mentioned
about keeping on at you about uh about
the issues in front of us uh as we see
them we supported the um amendment at
ovue and scrutiny we still think those
were good ideas we still are very
concerned about the housing situation as
i know everybody is i mean in my own
ward we've got three new couples living
in their cars this week
um and i'm sure that is reflected in in
other words across the aisle it's it's a
real concern and um
i do support council whitehead's view on
this i think it uh is eminently sensible
but um
we accept that it's a difficult decision
and cabinet has had to make the decision
they've made
on the matter of
climate emergency provisions
we are happy to hear that
that there is flexibility in the budget
we're happy to hear that external
funding is being sought
we are concerned that opportunities for
external funding in this field have been
missed in the past and we're really keen
to work with um officers and members to
make sure that we don't miss those
opportunities in future and we would
want to keep on saying
we need desperately in this area people
who are trained to retrofit housing and
anything that the council can do to
bring in money or set aside money to
help partner organizations contractors
and our own staff to develop those
skills would be immensely valuable
secondly that we do feel that when we're
investing in waste freighters we should
be looking at an electric freighter for
at least one of those to pilot that and
we have examples through the association
of green councillors of small
authorities with limited budgets that
are doing that successfully that we
would be very happy to pass on
likewise um with the current issue going
on about green waste the the nippiness
of small
freighters it gives us flexibility we do
appreciate that the new freighters are
to um deal with current issues and not
to expand provision but um there is
potential there i think to to look at
smaller
um more um cost effective in the end uh
vehicles that can manage our narrow
streets with the increasing numbers of
parked cars as more and more people work
from home so we're really keen to look
at that and we're also keen to
understand
the business case if that if that can't
be managed now that we feel it would be
really helpful for members generally to
have a more detailed understanding of
the business case for and against on
that and so that we can have a look at
how that changes over time
um and we have examples of all those
things available from other councils if
it's helpful thank you
thank you council austin um i think
before i hand over to to cancer saunders
that councillor joel bayford would also
like to to speak about the housing thank
you yeah just just um i want everybody
to know how uh how
in such depth that we we discussed the
proposals
i believe the housing team under bob
porter demonstrate a measured and
prudent approach to planning housing in
planet
they manage the hrf hra budget well and
are resourceful in funding projects
temporary accommodation is very
important to us and we feel its
provision will benefit from this planned
approach rather than using this
relatively small amount of money
available which would only fund two
units
we are also committed to helping to
provide stability by adding to our
reserves thank you
i think councillor bob bafe would like
to speak about his uh area there and
then our hand back to you council
saunders as the portfolio to sum it all
up if that's okay with you
yeah thank you chair um yeah just
addressing the issue of the the trucks i
mean you're absolutely right as far as a
decision about whether we have an
electric truck or not um economics are
going to come into play there you know
they are generally much more expensive
and i think you've already sort of
agreed that that you understand that the
two vehicles that we're looking to to
replace are in fact very old vehicles
you know they're past their useful life
they're being kept going on a wing and a
prayer and we need the large vehicles
because it's to actually support the
waste and recycling service which as you
know is sort of creaking at the street
seams anyway so you know we will be
going ahead with that as far as the
smaller vehicles concerned i mean
certainly you know wouldn't say that we
we wouldn't look at anything like that
that's for sure um but in a conversation
i had recently um it was pointed out
that in fact the smaller trucks are in
fact significantly less cost efficient
than the larger ones so they're you know
and happy to discuss at some stage
business case for things and of course
uh you know it's a good opportunity for
me to
assure all the council really that we
are really committed to this green
agenda of the climate change agenda
we've got a very active cad which is
meeting again on monday
at the next cabinet meeting we'll be
bringing forward recommendations that
came from the last cag i've had long
conversations with the climate change
officer hannah scott um where i've tried
as much as i can to reassure her that if
there are valid projects we will do
whatever we can to try and bring them
forward thank you
thank you councillor bayford and to hand
over to council saunders for his overall
summing up um
yes thank you uh councillor austin um i
think it came out loud and clear
yesterday at the gpc meeting um that
there is a need to involve members far
more
in decisions and we have taken that on
board and
as and when we can
we will involve and certainly if um you
know it's absolutely right that the
cabinet
don't necessarily have the overall um
information to their hand so it's it's
useful if members can come forward with
information that um is current is
current and and uh
the right information at the right time
other than that um i would just like to
say that you know we've we've looked at
all of the figures we've looked at the
proposals
our ambition our ambition was to produce
a balanced budget we believe we produced
a ballot balanced budget using prudence
and
i would say that don't judge us where we
start judge us where we finish and
our ambassador our ambition again is to
end the financial year 2022-23
without the budget gap that we've
experienced over the
several
last years
behind us and we want to put that budget
gap behind us
look forward
and uh
keep a balanced budget um with the
support of all the all of the budget
holders
and then see where we finish up this
time next year thank you
thank you all
thank you councillor saunders i think
that
summed it up really well and um
um
i'd like just to say thank you to the
efforts of all officers and members that
um put this together and um
i hope that um we can gain the support
of all members when it comes to um
voting through the budget on the on the
10th
we feel that we have been prudent and um
we feel that it's a good founder
financial foundation for for our future
so it has been
moved and seconded do i have cabinets
agreement
great
thank you
item five asset management investment
portfolio to introduce council larice
pugh
thank you chair uh members will know
agenda item five and the report that's
within it um is in relation to the west
cliff leisure park um whereas members
may know it more fondly as uh
alternative name is the boating pool in
ramsgate um the existing tenant has
released with the council for a term of
20 years which is due to expire in 2034
um
council is a new interested party as the
leaseholder is looking to uh so into the
lease
and we've already agreed heads of terms
members will note that i think it's in
annex 3 of agenda item 5 the proposal
by the new potential new leaseholders
i think it's an incredibly exciting
proposal and a project
particularly as this lease and this
lease has been surrendered
halfway through
its term
the proposed new tenants are requesting
a new lease for a term of 25 years which
will enable them to continue to invest
and develop property
and the lease will be a fully repairing
lease which i think is incredibly
important to note so they'll be
responsible for all repairs and
maintenance of the property um
so one the more final thing i'd like to
add before reading out the
recommendations is that the rental at
present is about ten and a half thousand
pounds per annum and it's been agreed
that this will stay at the current rent
for the first three years whilst the
proposed tenants invest their money into
the development and repair the property
the recommendation to enter into
a newer long-term lease will allow for
an uplift in rent after the third year
to market value and then there will be
reviews every five years which i think
is incredibly important for us as a
council to ensure that not only do we
receive adequate income for uh this this
asset in this building um
but that it's able to adjust over time
which particularly in light of covert i
think is incredibly important
so with that in mind i move forward the
five recommendations which are to agree
to surrender the current lease
agreements with the existing tenants to
agree a new lease with the proposed
tenants for an extended term of 25 years
and market rent for the premises listed
in nx1
to give delegated authority to the
director of property to finalise the
head of terms for the lease
to give delegates authority to the
director of law and democracy in
consultation with the portfolio holder
to enter into the relevant agreements on
the terms to be agreed and finally to
give dedicated authority to the director
of law and democracy to prepare and
complete the lease and all other
ancillary documents on the agreed terms
therefore i would like to
move this before cabinet
thank you councillor pugh do i have a
seconder councillor bob baffert
speaking under 20.1 councillor alban
thank you chair um thank councillor pugh
for that and uh just firstly you could
say um
the only bit of concern i had was you
saying that part of that was to the
director of
property but we don't seem to have at
the moment um
but anyway i'll go
just bear with us with that but
that's just a very minor point um
i'm actually
agreeing with you and i and i you know
instead of wouldn't argue with you i i
don't i actually fully support this
and i have to say that it's a
the the boating pool area as because i
use it myself
i use the cafe there etc uh it's a great
asset it's a great asset for the for the
residents and for visitors and
i
commend this
and also
and commend the deal that the officers
have done and yourself councillor pugh
for bringing us forward and uh i think
it's a great benefit for ramsgate and
that's all i wanted to say and thank you
chair
thank you council auburn actually we've
got some hot news on the um director of
property i'll pass over to the uh chief
exec who can enlighten you into the
the news
thank you uh thank you leader um just to
inform you that we do actually have a
director of property and interim
director uh at the moment but he's a
director he's covering the director of
property role stuart longbottom who
started yesterday so that's covered off
thank you
do you um want to come and respond to
council auburn
thank you chair yeah and thank you
council auburn um it's it's refreshing
to have so much support really uh
particularly in anything we bring to
cabinet council um
i can i
yeah well i i know you can't serve and
you like to keep me on my toes and i
appreciate that um you know i i
completely agree with what you've said i
think that particularly um
you know post covered and in the world
that we're currently in i think that
that part of ramsgate as well it's a
real opportunity to kind of energize
that bit particularly in uh with rounds
good future and the level and that funds
and everything i think this is a perfect
opportunity and
i think over the last couple of summers
there's been the pop-up bar there which
has been incredibly popular i've been
there myself and i've really enjoyed it
and i think it's a great thing that you
know these proposals have come forward
and the new leaseholders have got such a
refreshing and kind of new idea of what
to do with with the site i think that's
great i think for us as an asset in the
council it's incredibly important that
we
not only understand if a leaseholder
can't complete the full lease i think
that that is part of
a part of a part of life um but at the
same time it's great that we're
encouraging other people to take on the
leases and that they're enthusiastic and
they want to to dedicate so much time
and effort and money of course
investment um into our towns and into
ramsgates i think it's incredibly great
um
i mean you know there's not much really
to argue about is there so you know i i
don't really have anything else to say
council organ but i hope that anything
else i bring to cabinet and particularly
to do with assets in ramsgate or
anywhere else is this uh well received
thank you
thank you councillor pugh yes i i think
it's a it's a it's a great um
sign for fanec the fact that we've got
um
investors which this is coming in in an
industry that is notoriously difficult
catering leisure industries
is very difficult anyway and i can speak
with great experience about that um
a time when we're just coming out of the
pandemic and etc etc so they are brave
people because it is a difficult and
they will have to work very hard but i'm
sure and i've really got my eye on these
pizzas so they look really good so i i
shall hopefully be up there for one of
their first ones so um
so thank you to everyone for that so
it's been moved and secondly do cabinet
agree
so i do believe that that concludes our
business for the evening trials so i
would like to wish you all a good
evening and
look forward to seeing you at our next
meeting
thank you members
you